the new book Serenity in the storm
outnumbered co-host Kaylee mcineny is
with us along with former Arkansas
governor uh Mike Huckabee is with us
thank you both Kaylee start with you and
while he's obviously not prepared to run
the fact that the Democrats are now
considering well maybe we should go back
to Al Gore or Hillary Clinton that seems
like a sign of desperation to me and all
I see in the Republican Party
um you know from Trump on down is a deep
solid bench of really strong America
First make America great again
conservatives that would do a great job
in an Administration
sure it tells you a lot Al Gore Hillary
Hillary Clinton that's what we call
reruns it didn't work the first time
they're rerunning it it's in not going
to work this time there's a robust bench
to your point on the side of the
Republican party but Joe Biden I mean
this is he's going to be coordinated
that's what's going to happen he's not
going to have a meaningful primary
challenge Marianne Williamson we all
remember her not going to work out there
but what I remember is being on Air
Force One taking off with President
Trump he would be setting off for five
rallies I could barely keep up with the
man and then you would see Joe Biden's
team calling a lid at like 9 33 a.m
calling a lid meaning no more events for
the day he was able to sleep his way
through the 2020 campaign thanks to
covid-19 he cannot do that this time and
I've read reporting that his allies and
those who are supporting him are
counting on the fact that they believe
that President Trump will be the nominee
will pick a fight with the presidential
debate commission and therefore Joe
Biden will not have to debate good luck
with that because Trump trounced Joe
Biden in a debate last time around I
watched it it was the third presidential
debate counting on hiding again not
going to work
let me ask you Governor Huckabee um
we've watched these races unfold over
the years but really they seem to be
rudderless and when you talk to
Democrats even even privately nobody
that I know that's a Democrat wants him
to run again they all see what we see
they see a man that is frankly you know
weak frail and and struggling mightily
cognitively everybody sees it nobody
thinks he's physically or mentally up to
the job just if there's only a few of us
willing to say it publicly
well only 37 percent of Democrats even
want him to run I mean that's pretty
embarrassing when your own party
basically says you know six out of 10 of
you don't even want you to show up for
the battle but I think he's headstrong
to do it if they're going to go back and
get Hillary or Al Gore why don't they
just keep going back in history let's
maybe go back to their real icon FDR I
remember a few years ago Bear Bryant had
been passed away for quite some time and
Alabama was struggling in their football
program and there were bumper strips all
over Alabama that would say get the bear
dig him up I'm thinking that the
Democrats new slogan will be FDR dig him
up because that's where they're going
they're going to the Past not the future
and it may be the only shot they've got
all right exit question for both of you
does Gavin Newsom want to get in and
Willie get in Kaylee
once to get in we'll not get in Joe
Biden's about to be coordinated
and governor
wants to get in will get in and will be
cremated
all right I can't top that but I think
I'm with Governor Huckabee he wants to
get in I think he's going to find a way
in all right thank you both Kaylee and
Governor Huckabee Street hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else